I didn't know that picture was going to
be up
there ah hello everybody my name is
Brooke and I'm here to talk about a
project called Vibe
camp and share a little bit about what
we've done to nurture physical
manifestations of digital connections so
at present Vibe Camp is a gathering it's
somewhere between a festival an
unconference and a
retreat but the reason I'm up on the
stage right now is because Vibe camp and
the scene that we built it for have
already been doing a lot of the things
that I hear people and organizations
working in the network Society sphere
talk about wanting to do but often
struggle to
achieve however 10 minutes is not a very
long time so I'm mostly just going to
give a high level overview on what vibe
Camp is and if some of this speaks to
you I'm happy to go into more detail
later about how we've achieved some of
the things we
have so I joined Twitter in 2020 and the
algorithm kind of lumped me together
with the kinds of people I felt like I
had been searching for my whole life but
has struggled to find you're going to
see the term teot in this in a couple of
these slides in short for this part of
Twitter this bubble is sometimes called
that although that name and how to
define the scene is very hotly contested
so I'm also not going to talk about that
too much except to say that the aspects
that speak to me most are the kinds of
people who are maybe very smart very
kind and kind of weirdos people who
struggled to fit in with mainstream
institutions so Twitter algorithm lumps
together like mined people then Vibe
Camp Unleashed an avalanche of gathering
around the globe of increasing size and
duration Vibe Camp is an event built for
and by people who met each other on
Twitter so about a year after I joined
someone tweeted that they wanted to see
a multi-day gathering I quoted it and I
I pulled together the early team from
people who responded to that tweet and
so many lives have changed as a result
of that moment um we started meeting
weekly and we kept building in public
even the name Vibe Camp itself was
chosen by a Twitter post
and just a note about this event despite
being comprised largely of people who
spend all day on Twitter at Vibe Camp
people unplug and they connect face to
face so in this presentation you're
going to see a lot of tweets and not as
many
photos but what is it so I just wanted
to hang out with my Twitter friends but
it turned out that I had a lot of
Twitter friends and they had a lot of
Twitter friends and we just kind of hit
a cultural cord the first VI Camp was
over 400 people the second one took
place this year and it was around 700
it's multi-day there are cabins we
provide food and the content is all
co-created we don't hire speakers we
don't bring in hired acts anything like
that and a lot of it's even just built
on Twitter people will tweet maybe I
should do this at Vive camp or what do
you guys think about
that this is a just a nice tweet if
you're wondering what Vive Camp was it
was an eager War coming online the local
organizational principle of which is not
just love but boundless curiosity and
play and we had a big impact on people
there were a lot of people who went into
Vibe Camp also feeling like I had like
they didn't they hadn't been able to
find their tribe and a lot of them found
it
there I'm just going to do a couple
quick slides to give you an example of
the kinds of things that happen at Vibe
Camp uh this one was uh somebody set up
a typewriter and wrote poems based on
prompts this prompt was the first
sentient ai's Love Letter to humanity
this one was a collaborative Tarot deck
somebody got a bunch of attendees
together they all Drew their own cards
and then uh that was available for
purchase after
and at this last one there was a theater
production called the dating show to
save the world which was actually super
impressive it was really really well
done one Twitter user called it part of
the long tradition of alchemical
mythopoetic Storytelling which has its
roots in the Ancients and as branches in
our future but it wasn't without
controversy some people found some of
the themes upsetting or dark which leads
me to one of the things that I think is
the most unique about Vibe Camp which is
that Vibe Camp doesn't end when people
leave the site Vibe Camp end ends a week
or two later after people are done
posting long introspective threads on
Twitter about their experiences there
which is one of the really unique
aspects of this hybrid on and offline
thing this person says it's funny to
have a gathering of Twitter addicts
because it's like we all have the same
big diary so everybody's reflecting on
how things went but also seeing each
other's Reflections and reflecting on
those it's like a virtual decom but it
also kind of extends The Experience into
the wired fascinating and completely
novel he thinks so what he's referring
to there are like the Burning Man
decompression events which take place in
person they're Emeral they're they're
fleeting there's no real record of them
but with the sensemaking that happens on
Twitter for Vibe Camp there's a record
you can look back and see like oh this
is something people struggled with at
this event have we learned from it um
and also changes the nature of the
experience uh of the event for for
everybody because you get access to to a
perspective you never would have had
insight into and so it's kind of like
this whole journey that everybody goes
on together it's really
interesting we also do the people from
the crypto scenes will be familiar with
this there's like kind of the the Side
Event thing so Vibe Camp itself is 3 to
four days but the whole thing is more
like two weeks people just sort of we
roughly use our Discord server for
infrastructure but everything's very
decentralized people just get together
and do things one of our attendees
looked in that and thought well what
would happen if you take out the vibe
Camp so he just did a thing in in SF um
in August he managed to manifest around
80 people it was site events with no
main event they just got airbnbs
together they had Gatherings they had
meetups
but that's just kind of scratching the
surface to the kinds of things that have
been inspired by Vibe Camp manifest took
place this year um and that was uh one
of the co-founders of manifold markets
which is an online prediction Market
platform went to Vibe camp and thought
what happens if you combined Vibe camp
with something like eag which is a
conference for EA um and it turns out it
was phenomenally successful people loved
it this it was featured in New York
Times and that was particularly
meaningful for me because one of the
things that uh really motivated me to
create Vibe camp was a belief that when
you get smart driven people together in
a room they're going to work on hard
problems they're going to have
interesting conversations because that's
just what they love to do um but most
the containers built for those kind of
people things like conferences tend to
be very draining so the idea is like you
know be able to have these conversations
then go kayaking or go dancing join a
wrestling match I think it's uh
rejuvenating can be even more
generative but it doesn't stop there uh
the combined impact of vibe camp and
something called Jess camp that took
place around the same time in Europe has
led to this wave of camps happening
throughout the world and it's really
cool because if somebody can't make it
to like you know the vibe camp in the US
instead of being bitter or jealous they
say well how do I make that happen where
I am and then they go and do it there's
so many of these they tend to be named
after the person hosting them so this
one was run by a person named Kai but
there are so many of them that this
person asked what would a you camp look
like and the me Camp industry seems
promising so it's become like a whole
whole Meme and I think part of that has
to do with what this person called an
agency explosion and I I don't really
have clear answers on like how this
happened but I think it's related to the
fact that we were building in public uh
we had like basically little to no
events experience when we started out
and whenever people come to us and ask
is this happening at Vibe camp or what
kind of vibe will be there we asked them
like how can we help you create the kind
of event you
want we're a tribe everyone genuinely
cares so much that the world rearranged
to bring us together Brooke just
channeled lightning to make this happen
in 6 months because it was clear to her
how important it was we meet ASAP and
the thing is we can do it we are capable
of great change we own the means of
production we have loads of crypto money
floating around this was in March of
2022 and we have some of the best minds
of Our Generation and all this without
explicit coordination so that's kind of
what we're asking next is like what can
we do with explicit
coordination so again the algorithm
brought together like minor people we
unleashed an avalanche of gatherings
around the globe of increasing size and
duration and now it's time to build
something lasting I really like this map
that Richard Bartlett tweeted um you
know he talks about how we figured out
how to go from temporary to permanent
online relationships and with this wave
of camps it shows that we can do
temporary local community so what's next
is trying and figure out how to do
permanent local community so that's the
uh that's sort of the angle that we're
investigating
next and yeah so Vibe Camp it's run
mostly by volunteers we've gotten one
Rus Grant but other than that we we
survive off of ticket sales we do this
because we believe in the vast potential
of humanity and we believe in working
together towards a future where we're
all flourishing so if you'd like to
support us in some way if you'd like to
collaborate with us on events or if
you'd like to consult with us on how to
bring your digital Community into the
real world please reach out thank
you